in the face of a global health crisis
here's what novak djokovic thought the
world needed a series of tennis
tournaments rate crowds hugging and no
social distancing the Adria tour was
scheduled to crisscross the Balkans
after the event in Belgrade the players
went to a nightclub to celebrate sing
and have fun now all this has been
cancelled after Djokovic became the
fourth player involved in the tour to
test positive for coronavirus his wife
along with another player's wife and two
members of the support staff have also
contracted the disease Djokovic is now
in isolation in Serbia in a statement he
said I am extremely sorry for each
individual case of infection I hope that
it will not complicate anyone's health
situation and that everyone will be fine
this latest leg of the tro was being
played in croatia the whole events now
been canceled and contact tracers are
tracking down anyone else who may have
been infected the Croatian government a
really bad example of misbehavior of the
people in question but I think that it
will make other people more careful from
now on
criticism to from the world of tennis
Australian player Niki Rios said it was
a boneheaded decision to stage the event
Britain's top-ranked player also caustic
the Djokovic's do have strong opinions
he is against vaccines and indeed most
medical intervention his wife Yelena
circulated entirely unproven claims that
corona virus was linked to 5g technology
he is a sensational tennis player but at
a time when sport has shut down in the
face of a pandemic Djokovic's tournament
does look like an active ill-considered
follow
Adam Parsons Sky News